there's one more little topic that I
wanted to bring up and really it's it's
another question that I got it at jockle
live and I got this question or a
version of this question a couple of
different times and they all they all a
couple different versions of this
question but the same question and the
question is it's something like this
something along the lines of I've been
pretty successful at this point in my
life and I'm having trouble finding the
motivation to take it to the next level
so you know it's like people I say oh so
you you know you make decent money yep
but a couple yeah we're doing really
well and you work it out yep I'm a
healthy yep I'm good and your family's
taking care of you have a good time with
my family but you're not able to like
get the extra work out you're not you
know you're skipping some days you're
not eating great you're not making the
calls that you need to make you're not
expanding your eyes and that's what's
going on right and so that's we're
getting we get someone that's sort of in
a good spot kind of across the board
right kind of in a good spot across the
board and so I'd kind of established
that fact that they're in a good spot
across the board mm-hmm
and then I'd say but it sounds like
you're in a good spot across the board
are you happy with that and are you
comfortable with where you're at and the
answer would be no and then I'd say well
are you sure and then it's a young
Chiron you know I want to do more and
then I said
that's a lie that's a lie that's a lie
because if you really weren't happy and
you really wanted to improve your health
even more and you really wanted to
improve your financial situation more
and you really wanted to just broadly
improve your life then you wouldn't have
any problem at all finding the
discipline the discipline would actually
find you that's where I'm at that that
you want to know what people like oh you
don't see pretty much you want to know
why cuz this one finds me cuz I know I
will I know I can do more and I want to
do more and I know I'm not happy where
I'm at and comfortable where I'm at so
if you're telling yourself no I'm not
happy where you're at then I'm gonna
tell you that's actually a lie you are
comfortable you are comfortable because
if you weren't comfortable then it would
drive you the discipline would show up
now this is where I kind of I I kind of
have to go a little bit deeper so but
what I just said if you tell yourself
the truth then you'll find discipline
the framework of discipline is the truth
and I have to go and I didn't do a good
job when I got asked this question I
didn't do a good job of connecting all
the dots because it actually is one
level deeper it's one level deeper and
it looks like this if you're saying that
you can't find discipline and I'm
telling you it's because that's because
you are comfortable where you're at and
that is also a lie
that is also a lie look telling yourself
that you don't need to get out of bed in
the morning telling you something you
don't really need to work out or you
don't need to go Harger or you don't
need to do more in your job or be more
discipline in the way that you live if
you tell yourself those things that's
actually a lie because the fact of the
matter is think about this the fact the
matter is that you're not comfortable
you're not happy you're not ok with
where you're out because that's why
you're asking this question right now
you're asking this question because you
know you can do more you know you can be
more and that's the truth that's the
truth and it eats you up and it makes
you ask these questions ask the question
to me and ask the question to yourself
and the answer is the truth you know it
I know it we all know it that the
framework of discipline is the truth if
you tell yourself the truth the real
truth the absolute categorical
unconditional unabated unmerciful truth
if you do that you will find discipline
discipline equals freedom discipline is
rooted in the truth the truth will set
you free
and what does that calculus work out to
discipline equals freedom